good morning to all of you good morning
so welcome to the launch of the Metro 21
smart cities Institute here today we
have an eventful session talking about
various aspects of smart cities we have
a distinguished of speakers all day
we'll start with the interim president
of caning Brown University addressing
you it's my distinct pleasure to
introduce interim president Farnum Jehan
Ian to you Farnum has had a remarkable
career he graduated with his PhD in
computer science from the inertia of
Texas at Austin join IBM research Watson
Research Center in upstate New York and
became a manager they're working on a
fault-tolerant computing and then
transition back to academia became a
professor at the initial Michigan Ann
Arbor became the head of the department
of computer science and then had a
spin-off that he led a spin up named
Albert networks with quite a large
company here and that and then he became
the assistant director for NSF managing
computer science and information
information systems at the NSF then
actually he was recruited here at CMU to
become the vice provost for research
very quickly he was promoted to be the
Provost at CMU and then last year he
became the interim president so it's my
distinct pleasure to welcome fun
[Applause]
you know what Raj didn't tell you is
that I've known Raj he and I have been
friends and collaborators for about 30
years
the downside of knowing someone for 30
years is he goes back that far to tell
you my life story
thank you for your caring boardslides
thanks very much good morning everyone
it's such a pleasure to be with you and
on behalf of my colleagues here at
Carnegie Mellon it's my great great
pleasure to welcome all of you to the
launch of Carnegie Mellon University's
Metro 21 a smart city Institute which
has become a campus-wide initiative that
encompasses so much of our work at the
intersection of Technology and society
today is a celebration of a hard work of
a countless number of individuals both
within the university as well as outside
the university who have helped to
establish this institute that focuses on
technology's policies as well as
implementation I want to acknowledge a
couple of folks as as I go through my
introductory remarks as I mentioned this
includes individuals within the
university and outside
first of all among the leadership of the
university world with us today
Ramaiah Krishnan our Dean of Heinz
College who's here Jim Garrett who's our
Dean of engineering of course Raj who's
serving as director of Metro 21 Karen
Lippmann who is Metro 21s executive
director rick stafford who has
contributed to this effort for many many
years Chris Hendrickson of course and
Stan Caldwell please join me in thanking
not only the individuals as I mentioned
but rest of my colleagues at CMU have
contributed to this effort
none of this of course would be possible
without the support that we've had in
our partners in industry in government
and of course the wonderful foundation
community that we have here in
Pittsburgh that have worked together to
establish Pittsburgh as a global model
for innovative cities I'm delighted to
see a number of them here rich
Fitzgerald who's here our county
executive for that for Allegheny County
Corinna Rick's was a director of
mobility and infrastructure for the city
of Pittsburgh grand Oliphant of course
representing foundations I know Dave
Roger is here Brian Hill from RK Mellon
is with us and a number of colleagues
from industry including representatives
from Bosch Duquesne Light crown castle
and a number of others again please join
me in thanking all of our partners
who've contributed to this effort over
there today is not just a milestone a
wonderful milestone for Metro 21 it's
also an opportunity to celebrate the
progress we've made as as an institution
as a community to bridge the gap between
technology and people who use the
technology you know I joined this
university as Raj mentioned from the
National Science Foundation where I
headed the Computer Information science
and engineering Directorate and I've
tell you this was of course from 2011
through 2014 and the buzz at that time
during the previous administration was
how technology has become a vital part
of our nation's economic growth and
productivity and fast forward a few
years later it's undeniable we also
recognize that achieving the next
generation smart and connected
communities would require collaboration
between public and private sectors as
well as experts from many different
disciplines and different sectors in our
economy over the past decade and I think
most of you recognized is that CMU has
truly embraced this call to action of
course joined by partnership
with the city of Pittsburgh the county
as well as ours to the institutional and
industry partner the roots of our
collaboration I have to tell you is that
goes back in many years ago in 2009 and
the founding of traffic 21 Institute at
CMU at that time several Pittsburgh
bleeders including Henry Hillman
envisioned a revolution in
transportation that was powered that
would power advancement that was powered
by rather by advancement in information
technology and communication
technologies the Hillman foundation see
that the traffic 21 but also there was
tremendous support from the Heinz
endowment Richard King mellon foundation
Benedum foundation bill foundation and a
number of others in 2014 the continued
support from the foundations that I
mentioned we found that metro 21 as a
comprehensive initiative to look at
connected communities today we're
elevating metro 21 to a campus-wide
initiative that allows us to further
leverage the resources and partnership
we have to have greater impact on a
rapidly changing world I want to just
give you just for a minute or two my
perspective on why smart cities is so
important and and why it potentially has
such a huge impact not only on our city
but as a model for communities across
the world we need this more than ever
before today we find ourselves in the
midst of a global transformation that's
catalyze of course by rapid acceleration
and digital technologies we talk about
automation AI various analytics and so
on the intersection between these
increasingly ubiquitous technologies
that we see and also the global rise of
urbanization continues to shape our
world and how we live in it let me just
share with you a couple of anecdotal
evidence of this consider the following
in 2008 for the first time in the
history of humanity more people lived in
cities than in rural areas
in fact by 2050 2/3 of the world's
population which is projected to be
about nine point seven billion will live
in urban areas and other evidence of
that which is just surprised me the
first time I saw it over the last decade
the global urban essentially population
has been rising by an average of 60
million people per year with these
staggering trends that we see where are
the critical inflection points into
opportunity to tap the power of
scientific research and and
technological innovation to address the
most intractable challenges that face
our growing cities and humanity it is
essential that we bring the sense of
urgency to realizing transformation of
smart cities and of course I believe
that CMU is new uniquely position and
more importantly I think our community
in Pittsburgh and and the county is
uniquely positioned to lead the world in
this area smart city applications are
exciting frontiers for combining science
engineering public policy social science
architecture design and all of that
these things that we intertwine so
seamlessly on this campus as well our
vision for smart cities is to create a
more resilient inclusive and responsive
21st century communities of course it
has broad implications in energy
efficiency and sustainability and
automation transportation you'd be a lot
more about that today and much more but
put simply if you step back and look at
this we're really talking about
enhancing quality and delivery of urban
services increasing efficiency and
resiliency of city infrastructure
greater access to and inclusion more
sustainable environments using
data-driven decision making to flatten
the urban peaks if you will and finally
perhaps most importantly as our
government officials would attest this
create a more direct engagement by
citizens in shaping our communities